I believe that I personally can do a
whole hell of a lot better and so can
everybody else and I think it's about
the collective movement and not just one
individual so and what's great about
playing with these guys as they all care
deeply about that kind of thing whether
it's in songs they've written or not I
mean in our conversations there are
incredibly smart conversations about you
know different ways and means to walk
more cautiously and carefully through
every day so it's I I'm glad I'm really
glad to be doing it I'm glad to have
it's an honor to be presented on that
stage at this level and you know the
biggest part about putting the
environment first the ecology first is
it there's always room for improvement
always room to do better in that
direction